so you may have seen our video of a
block of carbon from the world's first
nuclear reactor which was given to a
minister of science when he and I
visited the Argonne National Lab in
Chicago well a few days after the video
a box has arrived from the Argonne
National Lab and I thought we might open
it together and see what's inside yet I
got a nice pen and the minister got his
block and I I suggested on the video
that perhaps the minister should give
the block to me and although he hasn't
yet asked for it back I haven't been
given it so let's see what's in the box
it says on the label that it is a
memento from the director of the lab so
I'm quite excited that it might be
something interesting you'll be real
happening if I cut myself on screen we
could do another video on blood ever the
professional I bet you do it though I
read the story or a letter from somebody
who said he'd started chemistry because
his chemistry teacher had an explosion
with sodium and was covered with blood
and still took out a piece of litmus
paper and put it in the water and said
look it's alkaline so inside is a
smaller box there's some quite
interesting packing material here could
be recycled Oh
inside here is a white box looks quite
like the minister's white box so let's
open it more packing and Wow
it's a block like the minister's this is
a block of graphite from the world's
first nuclear reactor that started on
the 2nd of December 1942 in Chicago
under the sports field so it's really
nice
I'm delighted so you're going to give
the minister's back though so I shall
give the minister's back so I think this
is absolutely great and I never thought
that I would have one of these to have
here at the University so when you come
and visit you'll be able to see this